percent and whether or not it is wise or
not giannis switches to the left hand
then comes back to the middle
what a great score in the restricted
area giannis out of the kumbho
or are they taking that away and this is
what we're so used to seeing from yannis
coming down
when i think you'll notice on both sides
here teams trying to get their rhythm
offensively because it's different when
you're doing those individual workouts
and getting shots
because you'll see bucks graphics and
san antonio is seeing the same
situation for their viewers yes
with the flush it's not easy to do
to plow through the paint explode it
looks so seamless
it's normal for him zara you're right oh
okay okay all right another one
softly this time eight of the bucks 20.
this for the lead
the final spot is between orlando and
brooklyn brooklyn apparently has been
given a much higher percentage
opportunity to get into the playoffs
when we get to the eight seating games
the bucks need to win two of those to
clinch the best record in the east
giannis with 12.
check that's of the eight and while
having the best record in the nba
doesn't mean they're gonna get
home court advantage where he really
needs to improve at i mean
he's worked hard on a nice pass right
there to find a
of dante he has great visions give
brooke
so much credit for what he does on the
defensive end the bucks lead 32-27 with
san antonio
i don't know if i can call a game and
eat at the same time giannis inside
and one so well let's try it see if i
can do a tater tot and talk at the same
time and that's a testament to their
focus
on the defensive end the spurs
trying to get something going
offensively
every other day the bucks have one today
another one on saturday and then the
final one
against new orleans on monday
lonnie walker the fourth is a
three-pointer suppose brook and robin
wouldn't let them leave before getting
the full disney experience
chris middleton with the steel hat in
the open court but wants to set things
up
giannis coming down the lane doing what
he does
and you see the body can wear that he's
got five fouls
giannis coming up the court weaves
through a couple defenders
gets delayed
[Music]
you raise a great point i'll bet
math i didn't want to say anything i was
waiting for it to happen
the sips team to get back into things
offensively giannis couldn't even see
robin there and still finds a way to get
to him
shimezhi meant to with the miss for the
spurs
well the nba was as giannis takes it in
for the double-handed flush
nice feed middleton might see in the
playoffs and there was a lot of thought
given into
which teams would meet i mean hey
number one in the league when it comes
to scoring
over 118 a game for the bucks 118.6
does that mean he won't be there at all
that is my
understanding okay
lonnie walker